[Music]
hi I'm Toby and welcome to the joys of
mathematics if you're an old viewer then
welcome back and if you're new there's a
chance you ended up here after watching
a now viral video of mine that I
uploaded three years ago called
VeggieTales predicts modern internet
humor the original video didn't get many
views at all until about a week ago
where it now has over a million the
video was copyright claims so I don't
want to show it again but here's a bit
of a live action replay for you after a
discussion about how in the future
entertainment will be randomly generated
Larry tells Bob that jokes are funny
when they are unexpected Bob asks
whatever happened to it's funny because
it's true Larry says two plus two equals
four is true but not funny they then ask
a robot who tells them that the answer
to two plus two is weedeater but that's
beside the point
we know that two plus two equals four
that's true or is it when proving
something in mathematics we have to
start with a series of statements that
can be taken as true without argument
these are called our axioms and
depending on which set of these
statements we choose will determine how
complicated it is to prove something
even if what we're trying to prove such
as two plus two equals four seems
trivial and obvious the axioms you start
with can be the difference between
fitting this into a video for YouTube or
taking 300 pages in a text book full of
sub theorems and exercises to even get
to this point today in this video we are
going to lay out the piano axioms and go
from there to try and prove that 2+2
really does equal 4 it's going to get
quite fundamental because we can't take
anything for granted we can't even take
numbers as a concept for granted we have
to define what numbers are before we can
start adding them to each other and
likewise we need to define what addition
even mean
before we go making any wild claims we
first want to understand what does
equality really mean what does it mean
to equal four we need to set up some
rules to follow so that we understand
what this actually means to us these
rules might seem to you too simple and
obvious to even bother writing down but
we really want to be precise here we
want to know exactly what equals does
what it means we don't want to have any
room for contradictions we're going to
define what numbers are soon but in the
meantime I've represented numbers of a
certain type with letters our first rule
is that X is equal to X you know one
variable is equal to itself so for every
natural number which is what we'll go on
to talk about an equality means that it
is equal to itself our second rule if X
is equal to Y then Y is equal to X it
doesn't matter if you're on the left or
the right side this equal sign it
doesn't matter whatever is on one side
is equal to what's on the other in math
we would call this symmetric it's a
mirror image of itself
our third rule is that if X is equal to
Y and Y is equal to Z then following our
logic here X is going to be equal to Z
in math we would call this transitive
our fourth rule is that if a belongs to
some group some collection we don't
really need to know what it is and a is
equal to B then this equality means that
B also belongs to that same group a and
B are said to be closed under equality
and anything they are equal to will also
be part of the same group these are the
laws that we need to understand what it
means to equal something and now at
least we can use an equal in our
equation and know that we defined it
from some first principles so now that
we have equality out of the way we can
start to think about what it means to be
a number and again numbers are something
you might think you're familiar with but
we really want to be precise we're going
to use the piano axioms which I
mentioned earlier and for the purpose of
writing on this chalkboard here I have
replaced a word you might have heard of
which is the phrase natural number with
a little flower a little natural flower
there the natural numbers are just you
know the numbers that you would come
things with 0 1 2 3 4 5 and onwards and
yes I am including 0 in this list that's
a bit of a personal choice I could have
chosen to just start at 1 but in fact
our first axiom is that 0 is a natural
number so number 2 our second rule is
that for every natural number in there
is this missive in which is said to be
the successor of n and it is also a
natural number you might think that you
are familiar with the idea of a
successor or the concept of next maybe
through ariana grande's hit song thank
you next maybe that will help you
intuitively but to be honest you don't
really need to know that this means next
you don't need to know what next is
because we're defining it through all
these rules
don't forget what we're doing here is
defining the natural numbers themselves
so you don't need to bring any
preconceived ideas to this we can just
start from here so if we have this
successor of n the successor to every
natural number and at this point we know
that 0 is a natural number then we know
there's going to be some s of 0 which is
also a number and natural number that we
can go on to use later on we could give
a label to this successor of 0 we could
give it our very familiar label of 1
let's look at another one of our rules
number 3 for natural numbers m and n m
is equal to n if and only if the
successor of M is equal to the successor
in this gives us a little bit more of a
constraint on what a successor can be
you definitely can't have two numbers
either equal to each other if their
successes aren't also equal to each
other so you can't have essentially
double ups where the successes are equal
but the numbers themselves weren't equal
so that helps us define recursively what
our numbers are going to be our fourth
rule here is that for every natural
number in the successor of n can't be 0
and that's alright it kind of amongst
other things rules out any of the
negative numbers being natural numbers
because through this way if we were to
have you know our next successor a
successor of 1 we could call that two
you know that we're not going to run
into any problems because we're going to
keep going that the successor of 2 is
equal to 3 and this would have only been
really been a problem if the successor
of minus 1 was equal to 0 which we can't
have so no success is equal to 0 and our
fifth rule is I haven't written it out
in full but I've called it induction it
means that if we keep defining our
natural numbers in this way say we're
going to have the successor of the
successor of 1 also known as the
successor of 2 we could call that 3 very
familiar names I'm assigning to them
then we can just keep going like that
and by induction this is going to
eventually give us our entire set of
natural numbers there's no room here for
you know a couple of random extra guys
to come in somewhere later down the
chain who only relate to each other in
terms of that they are each other's
successor and they don't relate to
anyone else who's come before them they
don't stand on the shoulders of giants
they're just in this own little loop of
their own well my induction
we've got no room we've got no time for
any of that this is the way that we are
going to define our natural numbers and
this is going to give us all of them
alright well now we know what numbers
are we've given labels to them as well
and we've only got one thing left to do
and that is to define addition the
reason that we need to define addition
is because addition really could do
anything it could be any function that
map's one number to another addition to
us seems so simple because it's a really
good way as we know it to describe
real-world examples if we have one ball
and we put it in a bag with another ball
then we have two balls and in that case
one plus 1 would be equal to two and we
would be very familiar with that idea
but we could have had some other
definition of addition maybe an addition
plus sign with a squiggle around it
which would add 1 and 1 to give us some
other answer if this addition was
defined to be just combining two balls
of slime you put one ball of slime and
another ball of slime into a bag well
what will you get at the end you'll
probably still have one big ball of
slime so in this way you could have you
know one plus one is equal to one it all
depends on your definition of this
function here on your addition so we
want to be clear about what we mean by
our addition symbol and it's going to be
defined recursively using these two
rules number one if you have a and you
add zero to it you're going to still
have a our second rule is that if you
have a you add the successor of B then
what you're going to have is the
successor of a plus B this makes sense
if you think of some examples from how
you're familiar with the addition say if
B was two you'd have the successor of
B being 3 plus maybe a is 1 so that
would give you 4 and then you'd have the
same thing here 1 plus 2 the successor
of 1 plus 2 would be 4 as well so hope
that these two rules of addition make
sense to you because now we're going to
use them to try and figure out our
elusive equation
2+2 now this is going to be equal to 2
plus well what was 2 from before we
defined 2 to be the successor of 1 and
using this second rule here about
successes this would be equal to the
successor of 2 plus 1 now let's think
about what one was from before what did
we define that to be we defined 1 to be
the successor of 0 so we can rewrite
this as the successor of 2 plus the
successor of 0 running out of room a
little bit on the board here now we can
employ rule 2 again and sort of rewrite
our brackets in a way so this is going
to be equal to the successor of the
successor of 2 plus 0 all right now we
can employ rule 1 from before if you add
0 to something it remains unchanged
we're adding a 0 to 2 in here so this is
all just going to be 2 so we've got the
successor of the successor of 2 getting
very close now the successor of 2 we
defined before when we were doing our
axioms as being the label 3 so now we
have the successor of 3 and the
successor of 3 is nothing at for itself
so there we go
by using our definition of addition and
also our way to construct the natural
numbers and thinking about what a number
actually is in terms of successes we've
managed to show that 2 plus 2 is indeed
equal to 4 if we want to think of a
little moral to the story we can think
about how our choice of axiom is
determined how easy it would be for us
to prove
later on we really want to have that
broad a detailed base and foundation of
knowledge to work from so that we can go
on to find out interesting things that
we know to be true doing it this way
means that we are relying less on you
know just believing other people and
believing in things and having trust and
instead we know this to be true because
we've seen it ourselves from the first
principles we built this foundation
ourselves and now we can stand upon it
to be confident and what we're doing now
and to be confident in going on to use
some of these ideas if you have a shaky
foundation of truths that you know to be
true without argument then it's going to
be hard to believe anything further on
and you might be more at risk of
believing things that actually turn out
to be false so if you are able to maybe
try to think more often about how to go
back and boil things down to a set of
statements that you can take as true
without argument and maybe those
statements are so fundamental they seem
trivial to write down but at least then
you will know what they are and you'll
know what's really important to you now
it is time to thank this episode sponsor
brilliant org across the bottom of your
screen
we'll be scrolling a few key areas of
mathematics and science which are
related to what we've done here today
these are all also courses on brilliant
org brilliant is a site where you can
take courses and quizzes on many
interesting areas of mathematics and
science and it's a great way to further
your mathematical foundations if you go
to brilliant not org slash tibbie's you
can sign up for free
and the first 200 people to use that
link can get 20% off an annual premium
subscription so thank you to brilliant
and thank you for watching
[Music]